some rivalries push a game forward we're
gonna dub this go easy vs sonic Fox the
session of the oppression some rivalries
make for the most incredible exciting
matches but some rivalries transcend the
game he took me out this time is in
winter side grand final one for set for
him and he's exhausted Sonic Fox and go
Ichi are two of the greatest fighting
game players of all time they came from
two different scenes to different
countries they spoke two different
languages but when they did come
together they created the greatest
rivalry in a fighting game history
he is your evo Dragonball Fighters
champion and damn right he deserves it
Dragon Ball fighters came out it seemed
position to bring together players from
all over the fighting game community
because well after all everyone's a
Dragonball Z fan and on that front
Dragonball Fighters was a huge success
bringing in players from Street Fighter
Mortal Kombat Super Smash Bros Marvel
vs. Capcom guilty gear and even more
obscure titles like melty blood and some
of those games very best came into
dragon ball swinging immediately two
names emerged as everyone's frontrunner
for the best player in the world in
Japan there was go eat a living fighting
game legend the best melty blood player
in the world and a master of what many
refer to as anime fighters
he's played like ever every poverty
anime game that you and I've never heard
of he's like multi-time champion
meanwhile North American fans were
rooting for Sonic Fox the best Mortal
Kombat player of all time and a talented
prodigy who succeeded at just about
every fighting game they've taken
seriously and master was barely a player
celebration sonic clocks just like that
once again the repeat yeah sonic Fox is
definitely like a savant right it's very
easy to see when he picks up any new
game how talented he is that it
immediately the pair dominated
tournaments in their own regions and
even traded verbal blows across the
Pacific so yes when he cooks oh one
thing go Ichi
oh my lemon she daddy meanwhile fans
were so excited to see them face off
that they even drew manga parroting
dragon ball in anticipation of their
inevitable showdown sonic Fox right he's
always been a dominant American player
so for him to step over cross over to
anime style game you already got a
respect the the people that was there
before anybody else which is the
Japanese players you know that people
overseas where these guys are just
masters at that game at the anime games
especially go eat scene I'm saying they
call him the the king of anime at final
round
the first major international tournament
after the game came out Sonic boxing go
easy based off in a first attend a match
that go Ichi one handle you know what
great job from Co Ichi
he called them out and he finished the
job that for for the obvious we knew
what we came to watch it was it pretty
and then just a few days later they
faced off in the tournament's grand
finals go Ichi started to set in losers
and beat sonic box 302 get the reset
where he narrowly defeated sonic Fox
again three to two that baby turns it
all she wrote as though weeks
goes into the loops final flesh it
coming after this energy field and this
is gonna be enough to through the top
don't eat see is your final Crown
champion
what a tremendous grand finals the
guarantee it's settled down don't we see
is without question the best in the
world but logo we teach triumph that
final round that match was just the
beginning of a year of back and forth
matches between sonic fonts and go Ichi
first came another first attended show
match but he's gonna deep into bed Jesse
does and go eats eats noises and then
combo breaker potentially want mix-up
away ladies and gentlemen's from taking
this away your combo breaker 2018
Dragonball Fighters champion and then
some of the power there to air you got
under or Box gonna take it away for you
out 4th place for going she in the
summit of power you know it's safe to
say I think at this point that is gooey
cheese demon heading at the evo 2018 the
pair were an even 3 to 3 in official
tournament sets it seemed like destiny
that they faced each other in the grand
finals of the biggest tournament of the
year the pair tore through their
respective sides of the bracket facing
off in winners finals and their hype
rematch was as insane as people at hope
but and then a lot quicker than many
expected
because the old things yes he is healthy
make some hero
the extra help you summon Shenron and
everything javelin come on is that
actually yes it is sonic boxing grand
finals winners side sonic fox13 oh but
after a swift win over his teammate
Fenric ghalichi clawed his way back to a
rematch with his ride gonna take out
Finn rich and give us a Grand Finals of
Sonic fox vs. go eat the win was quick
decisive and brutal though ichi resets
the bracket was a three oh that silenced
the doubters and proved he was ready to
reset we've got but sonic fox wasn't
quite as ready for the next set they
decided that they wanted the player one
side of the stage but the language
barrier prevented go ichi from
understanding what was happening for
five agonizing minutes
yeah the question sonic boss apparently
asked me if there could be a side switch
in between the sets he wants player one
note
but the rules say not son you can stay
right there now then wow what a shambles
a side switch what a gentleman like I
said I've been in the game since oh
three and that's always been the case
you can actually do that on the arcade
cabinets this is actually the first time
I see it in consoles like I never
thought I'd see the day where I see it
on a console like I mean I never thought
by the time the match got underway the
lychees momentum was frozen Sonic Hawks
won the set with a 300 and ended the
night as the best Dragonball Fighters
player in the world after that Evo
showdown sonic fox can go each he didn't
face each other for the rest of the year
it's not they didn't fallen off they
were still two of the best players in
the scene it's just that by the time the
world finals rolled around in January
2019 all eyes weren't as Anoka no go
your Dragonball fighters champion but
after failing to win or even face each
other at finals both players went into
overdrive going to start of the next
season like a rocket winning final round
again and then winning every single
tournament he attended NCR combo breaker
CEO he was literally unstoppable
meanwhile Sonic Fox is placing well but
they weren't quite reaching go easy in
bracket and when they finally faced off
a CEO go EG took the set to a
optimization
station my cup ouple those guys like not
if they had to yep yep I got you man
it's hot if I said yeah I agree and of
course go easy gold to the winners final
all this is to say that heading into evo
2019
go easy was the tournament favorite but
unbeknownst to most sonic fox took their
team back to the lab and got to work
crafting a new team to fight go ichi
they dished the masa who helped him get
the eva win the year before and picked
up kitty boo hoping that his assist
would help him break gooey cheese
legendarily unbreakable defense the two
tore through the bracket on a collision
course for winners fine and when they
finally met they played the greatest set
of dragon ball fighters the game has
ever seen
we have to meet every go slow sonic
wants to run bar talk to the office
instead of the GT goku air dash mix-up
needs to be careful with those bandages
i can tell you right now he might get
two eights misty air - cancel greet you
with a challenge gz go to assess old the
vanish sandwich and some back goals for
the overhead make some looking at the
deep it from luigi oh my god he's gonna
out block the entire sparky how they
still doing this right now replace out
the dragon rush that's a beautiful
whistling ish sonic was ready this is
his first big hit in a while
you're gonna set up the self-talk and
still get the free follower basket if
she could choose to take the mix up all
right gonna take the damage he wants the
mix-up oh he took the reset he wants the
reset for the mix-up because of that
he's not gonna take the extra damage
sandwiches them air nap cancelled over a
head again he flaps over a block you
can't block for if I may go each of you
you pretty darn close to doing it
example out for this time there's too
many options being thrown at Gucci for
him to stop everything eventually and
Sonic's really just grinding it down to
this man
level three that's gonna hit Bob he's
got a lot of meter to dump on this this
is a grip of damage next it kills kit
boo wake up under one three two just
like that six meter spent kid boos out
of there one character apiece old caught
he'll definitely could it be the band
then it's gonna be the game for sonic
[ __ ] that's gonna be two two two two
final game between these two in the
winners finals go eg vs. sonic box even
they look tired
oh man what a set powerful going to do
it 2019 he clutches it out last year he
took the out this time is in winter side
grand finals
one more set for him and he is exhausted
with an insanely close win goiti moved
on to the grand final the sonic foxes
run wasn't over yet
they clawed their way back with a 3-2
win over fen rich setting up the run
back that everyone wanted to see sonic
pops he's back in Grand Final in history
repeating itself once again you said it
at the beginning we're gonna say it
again at the end these two running into
each other again through finals he's
waving him over he's like let's play
wrong now I'm ready boy come on you I
want you come on come sit down buddy pal
have a top with uncle furry gonna tell
you real Adam go itches like all this
that's racing sonic box vs. go Ichi the
greatest rivalry in the fgc big damage
more than half life
he's got four parts oh I know character
dead yet so no Super Saiyan 4 but
village huh look at that the two M
starter file top of it that's gonna be a
damn character thumbs up looks low block
Shikoku that was a beautiful read from
Sonic so Luigi stayed on the ground he
wanted to challenge that's the kill also
by the way so he wanted to challenge
Sonic Fox was running up behind GT Goku
assist he hits diagonal up so instead
sonic fox jumped through a key blasting
out down knowing so we choose gonna hit
a ground it button it was a clean read
and if you're going that feels real bad
that's like missed and you should have
maybe jump the bed
drop the big pink matter
oh now sparking available for go Ichi
challenge outlets yokel weaknesses now
bro you got the character map it W when
he drops the whole bank drops the light
light asset that's a break on the dragon
right yeah you know Sonic's looking for
the tag level three
wow he calls them out gooey cheese on
one character between him and a reset
three zero Luigi hold the Dracula's you
knew what was coming
extend trying to get as much damage as
possible he built one Carl bar this
should be the kill level one go easy
pretty that back we're still fighting in
this first set you thought it was going
to be easy Sonic boxes like you know for
a second I did thank you Franken balls
locked and loaded behind the evil logo
but that's a mix-up fine switch not even
necessary to get the kill with the
javelin another level one rough spot for
Sonic talk tough fits the stuff we saw
those first two games go pretty clean
for Sonic Potts and alpha wheats is
winding it back
or that spirit Bob down
powerful he was reading the back - we
saw that in the first set
that's those keep laughing air-to-air
that's the kill hazal two characters
left go Ichi up back this is it and the
confirm with the long jump em that
should be the kill and it looks like
we're all tied up to a piece
a lot of things he asked six bars no
Sparky and now you
chunking this damage this is life you
won't get back you doesn't apps parking
available go eat you looking in complete
control to try to close out Evo went
through the assist and everything that
was crazy the assistant knocking down
with Bartok there so that song I
couldn't - out stagger pressure jumps
away catches the elbow this is huge the
game's all tied up sonic boxes down so
much the most part to care to the piece
five bars between them right now oh man
the blocks from Sonic jumps back Auto
complements the job back in five - smart
that's gonna be big damage he has five
floors yeah that's the end of kid Goku
here and that's the thing about gooey
cheese spin jumping and uh packing a lot
and really using that to throw off some
boxes timing catch stuff like that auto
call for whipping last character between
go Ichi and Evo championship candy
takeout sonic boxes Kid Buu box reset
the challenge going she was ready for it
he brings them up this is it drop up
keep it simple there it is go Ichi your
Dragon Ball
IVA Japeth after overcoming head injury
he's
of their defeating Sonic Fox
victory here I'm a winner sign
right that this has been eluding him for
so long last year he reset the bracket
sonic box plunged it out
GUI chief somehow just won his very
first championship for this game after
being so dominant for so long he is your
Evo Dragonball Fighters champion and
damn
he deserves it go EG cook grand final
was an incredible comeback from a 2o
deficit and end of the day as the best
Dragonball Fighters player in the world
the wind move go Ichi two-tier but sonic
fox wasn't off sulking with their head
down
they stood next to go Ichi the person
who just defeated them twice in front of
the entire world and raised up his hand
he wasn't just a champion he wasn't just
a rival he was a friend looking back at
every single one of their sets either
was mad when they lost to the other GU
Ichi and Sonic Fox transcended the
rivalry within the game and became
brothers in arms' perhaps fittingly they
paralleled the characters from the very
anime that Dragonball Fighters is based
on whenever Goku defeated an opponent he
tried to befriend them and maybe without
realizing it Sonic Fox and go eat she
did the same thing they came from two
completely different scenes to different
countries spoke two different languages
but they shared Dragonball they shared a
drive to improve themselves and each
other
they shared a love of fighting games now
they share a mutual respect a drive to
face off again and again to prove their
skill to the other thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
you